Merhabalar çok bağırıyor galiba Kerem
Avcı her gün Açı Okulları davet ettiği
için çok teşekkür ederim Umarım iyi bir
gündür keyifli misiniz gayet güzel bir
sunumdu
bugün size sivil toplum derken diye bir
sunum yapacağım aranızda daha önce hiç
sivil toplum hareketlerinde bulunmuşlar
var mı bir el görebilir miyim
fena değil
ilk soruyla başlayalım
kendini apolitik olarak tanımlayanlar
bir el kaldırabilir mi arkadaşlar Ben
apolitik bir insanım diyenler
var peki Ben Politik bir insanım
diyenler
aradayım ben bu tanımlara sığmam
diyenler var mı daha fazla şimdi
Müsaadenizle birkaç tane toplumsal konu
ortaya atacağım Bu konularla alakalı
Eğer bir duyguya sahipseniz bir
düşünceniz varsa bunları haberlerin
takip ediyorsanız meraklıysanız
dertliyseniz o konular hakkında ya da
benim bir çözümüm var ama dinleyenim yok
diyorsanız o konuyu duyunca lütfen el
kaldırın başlıyoruz Türkiye'de eğitim
iklim krizi
kadın hakları çocuk hakları
çevre savunuculuğu Spor
sanat
var mı ekleyeceğiniz
genç istihdam
iş konusunda belki dertlisinizdir bakın
daha da sayarız
Bu konularla ilgili herhangi bir el
kaldırılmıştınız henüz yoksa bilin ki
apolitiksinizdir eyvallah Ama eğer
herhangi birine el kaldırıyorsanız ve bu
konuda dertliyseniz bu konuda çözüm
üretmek istiyorsanız Politik bir
insansınızdır Türkiye'de bir tanım
problemi yaşıyoruz
bana sorarsanız toplumda bireylerin bu
bahsettiğimiz konular hakkında; birlikte
yaşamasını sağlayan
ve bunun kodunu kuralını kanununu
prensibini ilkesi tartıştığımız bir
çerçeve siyasetle ve politikadır
derseniz ki yaş olarak söylemiyorum ama
zihniyet olarak bazı dinozorların kendi
aralarında bizim geleceğimizi günümüzü
ilgilendirmeyen pek çok konuda
birbirlerine laf yetiştirmeleri
siyasettir bakın o zaman ben de sizin
kadar apolitiğim ama Türkiye'de bir
tanım problemi yaşıyoruz gençlerimiz ve
insanlarımız apolitik değiller bizim
siyaset ve politik algılımız ne yazık ki
son derece sakat ve problemli
bakın Biz vatandaşız
4-5 sene içerisinde 2 defa ortalama oy
veriyoruz yani gidiyoruz mühür basıyoruz
Bunun haricinde bu bahsettiğimiz konular
ne kadar önemli toplumsal konular
bunlarla ilgili bir söz hakkımız var mı
çözüm üretmemiz bunun için bir platform
bizim bir fark yaratmamız bir çözüm
üretmenin haricinde getireceğimiz bir
yenilik bunun bize sorulması böyle
ihtimaller var mı neredeyse yok
yok dediğimiz Aslında bizim hayatlarımız
ne kadar derinden etkileyen konular ve
bundan dolayı da Bizler bu 4-5 sene
içerisinde ne yazık ki bekleme moduna
geçiyoruz yapabileceğimiz tek şey gidip
Oy vermek Sivil Toplum ne derseniz bir
tanım olarak İnternette çok tanım var bu
bahsettiğimiz söz hakkı çözüm üretme
fark yaratma Bizler vatandaş olarak
aktif bir demokrasiye geçtiğimizde
demokrasi katılımcı hale getirdiğimizde
sivil toplum yeşeriyor ve topluma ve
ülkeye çok büyük fayda sağlıyor bana
sorarsanız sivil toplum budur
peki hani şöyle ben kendimi tanımlarken
Ben bir aktivistim ben bir sivil toplum
için bir sosyal girişimciyim ve çok
şanslı bir insanım kendim böyle
tanımlayabildiğim için nasıl başlıyor
derseniz çok kısa bir CV tadında geçeyim
99 depreminde gönüllü olarak bölgeye
gittim daha o zaman 17 yaşındaydım
Sizler de zaten şu an 17 olanlar bir el
kaldırabilir mi genelde 17-16 değil mi
hainsin zaman çok zaman geçmiş 99'da
gittiğimde çok gençtim ilk defa bir Kriz
anı ilk defa bir afet çok şey öğrendim
arkasından
2013'te gezide barışçıl bir
protestocuydum bende sivil toplum olarak
protesto hakkımızı kullanıyorduk
2014'te oy ve Ötesi Derneği ile
karşılaştım oy ve ötesinin 3 sene
boyunca hemen hemen her kademesinde Okul
sorumluluğundan Kadıköy sorumluluğuna İç
Anadolu Bölgesi'nin sorumluluğu Türkiye
Eğitim koordinatörlüğü sonra yönetim
kurulu buralarda görevi aldım
Daha sonra referandum geldi parlementler
sistem için sivil toplum olarak bir
hayır kampanyası düzenledik 4-5 ay
oldukça çalıştık sonra 16 Nisan 2017'de
parlamenter sistemimizi kaybettik
sonrasında is hareketi temiz hasat
tüketim Kooperatifi gibi kuruluşlarda
Kurucu ve yönetim kurulu görevleri
yaptım sözcülüklerine devam ettiriyorum
kanserli çocuklara mutfak fonun bir
gönüllüsüyüm çevre aktivisteyim ve aynı
zamanda çocuk hakları üzerine çalışmalar
yapıyoruz bakın Ne kadar farklı pek çok
konu ve bunlarla ilgili çalışabilecek
bir insan
ve benim etrafımda çok fazla bu
konularda çalışan insanlar var fark
yaratmaya çalışıyorlar çözüm getirmeye
çalışıyorlar Peki buna nasıl başlanıyor
sivil topluma nasıl gireriz diye konuşan
ve soran insanlar geliyor tek bir cevap
var bir motivasyon genelde dertlenme ile
geliyor dertlenmeniz gerekiyor herhangi
bir konuya demin farklı farklı konulara
el kaldırdınız benim kendi hikayemdeki
bu motivasyon işte 99'da depremin olduğu
Pazartesi akşamı istanbul'daydı
evimdeydim ev böyle gitti geldi
sallandık Neyse ki oturdu ertesi akşam
gece ben yatağımda uyuyamadım
[Müzik]
gaz altındaki çocukların canı olup
olmadığını söylemesi son derece
travmatik bir tecrübeydi ama çok şey
öğrendim
sonra Kendi başınıza gelen dertler
üzerinden de motivasyon sağlıyorsunuz
sivil toplumda 34 yaşındaydı Çok yakın
bir arkadaşım Sinan onu kansere
kaybettik
genç yaşta kanser konusu bizim için bir
hassasiyet oldu ve Sinan'ın annesi
kanserli çocukları mutfak Vakfı kaç
yılla irtibata geçti o günden beri de
onun gönüllüsüydü fark ettiyseniz
dertlendiğiniz konular sizin
motivasyonunuzdaki en büyük kaynak
oluyor bana pek çok kişi soruyor Ben de
sivil toplumda bir şeyler yapmak
istiyorum Nereden başlayabilirim diye
kalbinizin sesini dinleyin Çünkü sosyal
medyada Çevrenizde bu tür konular
hangisi olursa olsun sizi harekete
geçiriyorsa sinirlendiriyor öfkeliyor
üzüyorsa O konudan başlamanızda fayda
var
sivil toplum ve bazı bölüm maddeler
böyle bazı mihenk taşları var Arkadaşlar
biraz bunlardan bahsetmek istiyorum ki
Belki bu yolculuğa girersiniz orada size
yardımcı olur Belki de bu genç yaşınızda
ileriye dönük dönemlerde farklı
girişimlerde bulunursunuz buralarda
kullanırsınız birinci konu Bizler sivil
topluma adım attığımız anda kendi
fanusundan dışarı çıkıyoruz Bakın ben
Kadıköy'de doğdum büyüdüm benim
hobitadım kültürüm Kadıköy
Fenerbahçe'de bir devlet listesinde
okudum Sonra özel okulda İstanbul'da
arkasından yurt dışından Amerika'da
üniversite fanusun buydu benim
son 10 senedir Türkiye'ye ilçe ilçe ve
köy köye geziyorum Çok ücra köylere de
gidiyorum benim puanımdan Dışarı
çıktığımda gördüğüm karşılaştığım ortam
kültür sosyal ekonomik durumlar
düşünceler insan ilişkileri çok farklı
çok farklı ve insan dışarı dünyayı
keşfederken Aslında keşfetmeye başlıyor
Çünkü bu farklılıklara sizi nasıl tepki
verdiğiniz Aslında sizin de ilk defa bu
tepkiyi görmeniz böyle dışarı çıkıp
kendinizi izlermiş gibi bir havaya
büründürüyor kendi filminizi
izliyorsunuz ve şaşırıyorsunuz ilk defa
o fanus dediğimiz Konfor alanından
çıktığınız zaman zorluklarla ve
farklılıklarla karşılaşıyorsunuz sivil
toplum insanı son derece geliştiren o
kişisel yolculuğuna çok büyük katkılar
sağlayan çok farklı bir olgu
bir sonraki aşamaya geçiyorsunuz o fanus
Size bazı tokatlar vurmaya çalışıyoruz
farklı fanuslar Soma'da sosyal haklar
Derneği ile bir yaz okuluna gittik iki
sene geçmişti soba facia maden
faciasının üzerinden çok travmatik bir
bölge Burası Biz orada 200 çocuğa
madenci ailelerin çocukları ya da tarım
işçilerin çocukları yazın bedelsiz bir
yaz okulu düzenlendi Ben de o dönem bir
spor ajansım vardı spor Malzemelerimi
götürdüm işte spor bilgimi getirdim
çocuklara oyunlar oynatıyoruz 3 hafta
inanılmaz bir tecrübeyde Çünkü o fanus
oradaki fanus bana dedi ki
Sen bu insanların neler yaşadığını
hiçbir zaman bilemezsin ve
bilemeyeceksin oturduğumuz yerden gözlem
yapamıyoruz tahminlerde bulunuyoruz
yaklaştığımızda gözlem yapabiliyoruz ama
yaşamak çok başka
çocuklara futbol oynuyorlar iki tanesi
birbirine girdi Kavga ediyorlar Ben de
gelin bakalım dedim ayırdım onları sağda
köşede oturttuğum yere anlatın derdiniz
dedim Yani benim de amacım şu şu işte
çocuklar gerek yok buna şiddetsiz
iletişim çok önemli bu mimaride bir
şeyler demeye çalışıyorum
çocuklarla göz hizasına gelmek için
böyle Dizlerimin üstüne çöktüm Hani olur
ya böyle bir tanesi ağrır öbürüne
ağırlık verirsiniz böyle şöyle bir hamle
yaptım bu kadar çocuklar zıpladılar
geliyor irkililer diyor sapsarı oldular
anlatamam o andaki şokum böyle de şokum
var
nasıl olabilir böyle bir şey yani ben
böyle bir beklentiye Nasıl soktum size
ya konuyu özneyi kendim sanıyorum özne
ben değilim ve değilmişim
sonra rehber ve öğretmenler var
arkadaşlarla konuştum bundan bahsettim
dediler ki bu çocuklar çoğu Hepsi değil
tabii ki ama ailede şiddet görüyorlar
farkında değil mi sinirler Sabahları
geldiklerinde Kulakların arkası kırmızı
oluyor bazı morluklar şişlikler
olabiliyor
bir köye gittik ailece bizi sağolsunlar
davet ettiler bahçede böyle sandalyeler
kondu yuvarlak Hani hepimizin oturduğu
konum o Yuvarlağın merkezine bakıyor
dahil oluşturduk sohbet ediyoruz Tabii
ki kadınlar biraz daha bu tarafta
Erkekler biraz daha o tarafta Beklediğim
bir şeydi ailenin iki tane gelini onlar
da ordalar Ama onların ikisinin de
sadece ikisinin sandalyesi Yuvarlağın o
dairenin ortasına bakmıyor
kayınvalidelerin yüzüne bakıyor
sohbete dahiller gibi ama aslında
değiller Çünkü kontrol merkezinden de
çıkmıyorlar ve bunun gibi binlerce
hikaye ve tecrübem var Bunlar o
fanusundan çıktığınız zaman sizin hayatı
Türkiye'deki sosyal yapıyı dünyadaki
sosyal yapıyla alakalı çok şaşırtıcı ama
çok da tecrübe ettiğiniz konular sivil
toplum size bize bunu katıyor bir
sonraki aşama
sivil toplumda Reaksiyon ve aksiyon
arasındaki fark O da şu; bakın mesela
gezi direnişi son derece reaktif bir
hareketti
tepkiselde kitlesel ya da bireysel bazı
konularda Biz çok düşünmeden belli kısa
bir sürede herhangi bir amaca yönelik
olmayan tepkiler verebiliyoruz mesela
iklim aktivistleri son derece takdir
ediyorum ama son dönemde bu hani Sanat
eserlerine turuncu boya atıyorlar ya
kabul edebileceğim bir şey değil
aktivizm cesaret ister ama yıkıcılık
başka bir yere kadar çünkü yıkıcılık
Eğer
gösterdiğiniz Reaksiyon o aktivizm sizi
Başarıya hedefinize ulaştırmıyorsa Bir
süre sonra sizi törpülemeye başlıyor ve
tam o anda o enerjinizi
reaksiyondan aksiyona çevirmek
zorundasınız aksiyon da daha planlı uzun
vadeli hedefleri başarıları tam olarak
neye ulaşmayı istediğimiz belli olan
kurumlar projeler ve programlar
enerjimizi buna harcamaya başladığımız
zaman daha da rahatlıyoruz benim için de
böyle oldu gezi sonrasında oy ve Ötesi
Derneği Türkiye'de sivil denetim
getirdiğimiz bir sandık organizasyonu 3
sene boyunca inanılmaz bir kurumsal yapı
arkasından dedim ki ben bunu daha da
ilerletmeliyim Çünkü daha kalıcı
Türkiye'nin çok daha farklı şeylere
ihtiyacı olduğunu görüyoruz ve
arkadaşlarımızla yaptık görüşmeleri
dedik ki; Türkiye'nin
toplumun inanılmaz bir ekonomik ve
sosyal Kalkınma hamlesine ihtiyacı var
Ve bunun için eğer bizim yetkimiz yoksa
etkimiz olabilir Ve bundan dolayı dedik
ki; sivil toplum son derece birleştirici
bir Unsur ve yapmamız gereken şey
özellikle anahtar olan kadınları
güçlendirmek ister hareketini bunun için
koyduk daha geleli mahallelerde son
derece ne zamantajlı insanlar Özellikle
de kadınlar sorduk Neye ihtiyacınız
olabilir Size ekonomik ve sosyal olarak
nasıl geliştirebiliriz diye çok ilginç
cevaplar aldık ve onları bu konularda
bilgilendirdik pek çok atölye yaptık
uzmanları çağırdık bir haftada çok az
bir şeyle Çocuğunuzu nasıl sağlıklı
besleyebilirsiniz çok ilgilendiler
ergenlerle iletişim sorunlar yaşıyorlar
Psikologlar Pediatri Bunun haricinde
meslek atölyeleri yaptık afet yönetimi
üzerine destekler verdik Ve bu insanlar
bakın çok uzaktaki köylere kitap
yollamak böyle daha farklı sivil toplum
Bunlar da seçilebilirdi ama hemen yan
mahallemizde bilgiye ihtiyaç duyan ve bu
bilgiyi bizim sağlayabileceğimiz pek çok
insan var arkasından Temmuza Satı temiz
hasat kooperatifini kurduk dedik ki
Türkiye'de kadın tarım bunlarla ilgili
bir şey yapmamız gerekiyor bizim
gücümüzle tüketim gücümüz var Gidip de
marketten yaptığımız alışverişler yerine
bu köylere döndük bakın tarıma devam
edin dedik Biz üretici üretimi tüketimle
destekleyeceğiz dedik ve bir kooperatif
kuruyoruz Dedik size marketten
yapacağımız alışverişler yerine
sizlerden alışveriş yapacağız Siz ekmeğe
devam edin içine pestisli tatmayın gıda
güvenliği çok önemli ve buna devam
ederseniz bir Örnek Aile para kazanmaya
başlar alım garantisi veriyor çünkü
onlara o aile genişler çoğalır ve biz
bir süre sonra elimizdeki sermaye ile
bakın bunlar bağlaş değil zaten bizim
yarattığımız ekonomik bir model o
köylerde üretim atölyelerine geçeriz
dedik farkındaysanız projelerden böyle
vurkaç projeler süresi 1 ay 2 ay ya da
bir yıl değil daha uzun devam eden
projelere döndük kadını güçlendirmeye ve
toplumu kalkındırmaya çalıştık son
olarak biraz daha afet yönetiminden
bahsetmek istiyorum Türkiye'ye de sivil
toplum o kadar değerli ve o kadar güçlü
ki
bakın Biz bir afet ülkesiyiz onu kabul
etmemiz gerekiyor
dua ne yazık doğa faizaları
gerçekleştiğinde şehirleşmemiz ve
özellikle risk yönetimimiz bizim yeterli
değil Bunu son dönemde son 2-3 senedir
Çok acı bir şekilde yaşıyoruz ve şunu
yapıyoruz
sivil toplum olarak ben Marmaris
yangınları demin bahsedildi çok çok acı
bir dönemdi gittiğimde sahaya şunu
gördüm koordinasyon yoktu pek çok orman
ekibi itfaiye kimin nerede olduğunu
kimse bilmiyor herkes başı kesilmiş
tavuk gibi koordinasyonsuz bir şekilde
çok büyük bir arazi o yangın söndürmeye
çalışıyor dedik ki
Biz koordinasyon getirebiliriz bakın
böyle bir networkümüz var
tek tek araçlarla o ekipleri bulduk o
ekiplerin gün gün nereye gittiğini takip
ettik Neye ihtiyaçları olduğunu öğrendik
hortumları zarar görmüştü rekorları
kırılmıştı botları yanmıştı aklınıza
gelebilecek pek çok malzeme ve erzak
kimine İstanbul'dan Ankara'dan getirttik
belediye ile görüştük bir depoya yığdık
o Depodan bu ekiplerin tam olarak
ihtiyacın neyse onu sağlayıp kendi
araçlarımızla onlara gönderdik bu neyi
sağladı inanılmaz bir yığılma oluyor
erzak desteğinde ekipman desteğinde bu
israfa dönüyor Halbuki talebe göre arıza
ayarlarsak ki sivil toplum buna yaptı
çok daha verimli çalışabiliyoruz aynı
şekilde depremde de canlı nerede
doğru bilgi midir bilgi kirliliği
inanılmazdı insanlar yüzlerce sivil
toplum Network ekranlarında ve
telefonlarında bu arama kurtarma
ekiplerini oraya yönlendirdiler hala
devam ediyoruz araba kurtarma sonrasında
Şimdi de gıda destekleri aklınıza
gelebilecek pek çok insani destek sonuç
olarak Türkiye bir afet bölgesi ve sivil
topluma ihtiyacı var inanılmaz da bir
potansiyeli var ve devlet kurumlarıyla
bunu birlikte yapmamız gerekiyor ve
paylaşmamız gerekiyor
Sizler Eğer sivil toplumla ilgili ya da
demin el kaldırdığınız konularla ilgili
Eğer bir hassasiyete sahipseniz şu an
Tabii ki zor yani çok sınavım var bana
bulaşmayın diyebilirsiniz son derece
haklısınız Bir sonraki aşamada iş bulma
sonra kariyer sonra aile sonra çocuklar
genelde zaten sivil toplumun yaş
ortalaması biraz yüksektir ama ben
şahıslıyım ve Belki siz de şanslı
olursunuz girerseniz maceraya bilin ki
pek çok insan toplumu değiştirmek için
Yola çıkıyor ama aslında kendimizi
dönüşürken ve gelişirken buluyoruz
arkasından yarattığımız faydalar sadece
yanımıza kar kalıyor ve geleceğe ve
geçmişe çok güzel izler bırakıyoruz
Umarım bir gün sizleri de yanımda
görürüm Çok teşekkür ederim sağ ol
[Alkış]